[Music]
ursula k le guin's fifth earth sea book
tales from earth sea is a little bit
different in that it's not a
novel but rather contains short stories
some of them shorter some of them longer
and it begins with a story
the finder that has several different
parts to it and is one of the longer
stories and it tells us
the origins
of
rogue as an institution not as of course
an island but as the place where we have
the famous school
and the institution of the masters and
the arc mage and she tells us that
this is a tale of those times meaning
the times before
roque was established after the kingdom
began to come apart some of which he
says is taken from the book of the dark
some comes from hovnor from the upland
farms of ahn in the woodlands of
fellaiarn a story may be pieced together
and though it will be an airy quilt half
made of hearsay and half of guesswork
yet it may be true enough it's a tale of
the founding of roke and if the masters
of rogue say it didn't happen so
let them tell how it happened otherwise
for a cloud hangs over the time when
rogue first became the isle of the wise
and it may be that the wise men put it
there so this is going to tell us
the story in ursula k le guin's own
narrative universe of earthsea about how
things
came to be and she begins by telling us
about this book
the book of the dark written 600 years
ago
in on enlarge and we'll read a passage
from it shortly but it's important to
see what she also observes about this
she tells us the book of the dark
written late in the time it tells of is
a compilation of self-contradictory
histories partial biographies and
garbled legends but it's the best of the
records that survived the dark years
wanting praise not history the warlords
burnt the books in which the poor and
the powerless might learn
what power
is
this is a very important theme we are
dealing with a time in which earth sea
which is always dangerous to some degree
you could die out on the sea you'd be be
incinerated by a dragon
people could take you as as slaves in
the southern reaches or things like that
you could get a sickness and die but it
became particularly dangerous
in a time of political breakdown
and instability and magic played a role
in that but
really the
key thing here is power power was being
misused and
misunderstood so without a king in
earthsea as we're going to see
social order breaks down and you could
say the moral order itself breaks down
and we wind up with a rather
dark and dangerous condition so here's
how the
book of the dark begins
after el faron and morad perished in the
isle of solaya sank beneath the sea
the council of the wise governed for the
child serada until he took the throne
his reign was bright but brief
the kings who followed him and endlad
were seven and their realm increased in
peace and wealth then the dragons came
to raid among the western lands and
wizards went out in vain against them
king akambar moved the court from berlin
and lad to the city of havnor whence he
sent out his fleet against invaders from
the car god lands and drove them back
into the east
but still they sent raiding ships even
as far as the inmost sea of the 14 kings
of havnor the last was maharian who made
peace both at the dragons and the kargs
but at great cost so it sounds like
things are going to be going good from
that point on but
mahari on the
brave was killed by treachery and it
seemed that no good thing happened in
the archipelago
so we have you know a unified earth sea
except of course against the kargs who
are a different ethnicity you could say
a different culture they're fighting the
dragons are coming in they beat them
back
and then things break down what happens
after the king dies
many claimed maharian's throne but none
could keep it and the claim the quarrels
of the claimants divided all loyalties
no commonwealth was left and no justice
only the will of the wealthy
men of noble houses merchants and
pirates any who could hire soldiers and
wizards called himself a lord
claiming lands and cities as his
property the warlords made those they
conquered slaves and those they hired
were in truth slaves having only their
masters to safeguard them from rival
warlords seizing the lands and sea
pirates raiding the ports and bands and
hordes of lawless miserable men
dispossessed of their living driven by
hunger to raid and robbed so we have a
lot of different types of breakdown we
have a breakdown of the commonwealth
itself into you know
we can't even really call it feudalism
because there's nobody at the apex to
command loyalty upward rather each
person sets themselves up as he says of
the warlord and calls themself a king
but their their kingship is only
respected within their borders and
whoever has
power or
wealth or other resources can dominate
others can suck them into
their own
network you could say of of slavery and
so
this is indeed
a dark time
and as she goes on to tell us we don't
just have the book of the dark we have
the lore books of wizards
which sometimes record
some things as well these random records
reveal a clear moment here and there the
all between those moments in is darkness
like glimpses of a lighted ship far out
to sea in darkness in the rain there's
also songs old lays and ballads from
small islands and from the quiet uplands
of havnor that tell the story of these
years so what what is the story of those
years
well she goes on and she says
that in the dark years
wizards sold their arts or their skills
to the highest bidder
pitting their powers one against the
other in duels and combats of sorcery
careless of the evils they did or worse
than careless so wizards themselves are
doing something similar to what the
warlords are doing they encounter each
other they try to master each other as
we see depicted here in this book and
the wizards also sell their their arts
to
powerful lords
as well and they're careless of the evil
that they do they don't think about
anything like the equilibrium that we
see the mages of earthsea so concerned
with
he tells she goes on to say plagues
famine failures of springs of water
summers with no rain years with no
summer the birth of sickly and monstrous
young to sheep and cattle the birth of
sickly and monstrous children to the
people of the isles
all of these things were charged to the
practices of wizards and witches and all
too often rightly so
like
those engaging in warfare
in our own time they are poisoning the
environment they're causing birth
defects they are you know destroying
other people's livelihoods as a result
so the common people and the strong
really do in fact distrust the wizards
and the witches the common people
sometimes rising up against them as we
see here it became dangerous to practice
sorcery except under the protection of a
strong warlord and even then if a wizard
met up with one whose powers were
greater than his own he might be
destroyed if a wizard let his guard down
among the common folk they too might
destroy him if they could right
in those years in the minds of most
people all magic was black it was then
that village sorcery and above all
women's witchery came into the
ill-repute it is clung to that has clung
to its sense which is paid dearly for
practicing the arts they thought of as
their own
care of pregnant beasts and women
birthing teaching the songs and rights
the fertility and order of field and
garden the building and care of the
house and its furniture the mining of
oars and metals these great things had
always been in the charge of women a
rich lore of spells and charms to ensure
the good outcome of such undertakings
was shared among the witches
but when things went wrong
at the birth or in the field that would
be the witch's fault so
the destructiveness of the wizards is
affecting the the magic that the witches
are using and they themselves are being
held accountable sometimes for things
they're doing very often for things that
they're
not doing the strong also distrust the
users of magic and will try to wipe them
out if they're not working for them or
being brought underneath their
their umbrella
at the same time the strong
those who have wealth those who have
power are enslaving
and exploiting the weak those who
lack these things and it's generating
more and more
misery
distrust and
you know a lack of
development or even going backwards
throughout the lands of earth sea
and island will turn against island as
well
so this is indeed a bad time
um
like she goes on talking about witches
and wizards the practice of their lore
and the teaching of it had become
perilous those who undertook it were
often those already outcast crippled
deranged without family old men and
women who had little to lose
the wise man and wise woman trusted and
held in reverence gave way to the stock
figures of the shuffling impotent
village sorcerer the hag which with her
potions and a child's gift for magic
became a thing to dread and hide and
what we find is the main character
throughout the rest of the story otter
also known as medra by his true name
is a child who's born with the capacity
for magic as it turns out a great
capacity and this is sniffed out
by the hound a person he himself is is a
magic user and his main talent is for
finding magic um
the
local warlord lowson who calls himself a
king of hovnor even though he has no
cause for that is sending out ships that
otter's father helps to build an otter
introduces a spell not one that will
destroy the ship or anything but one
that will make it never steer quite
right because it's being used for
slavery and
otter
gets found out by the hound and what
does the hound tell him the hound is
interrogating him
and he asks him you know can you do this
can you do this
here's a very interesting passage it was
hard for him otter to lie he thought it
he was awkward at it because he had no
practice but the hound knew better
he knew that magic itself resists
untruth conjuring sleight of hand false
commerce with the debtor counterfeits of
magic last to the diamond brass to the
gold their fraud and lies flourish in
that soil
but the art of magic even if it may be
used for false ends deals with what is
real and the words it works with are the
true words so true wizards find it hard
to lie about their art in their heart
they know that their lie spoken may
change the world and he tells
the young boy this is what the hound
says you know if it was gaelic
questioning you
he'd have everything you know out of you
with just a word or two and your wits
with it i've seen what happens when he
asks questions and then he goes on
further and he says would you be willing
to use your skills in the king's service
and otter says there is no king in
earthsea
in our my master's service then hound
amended patient
no otter said he felt he owed this man
an explanation it's not so much won't as
can't i thought of making plugs in the
planking of that galley you know what i
mean by plugs they'd work out as the
timbers work but i couldn't do it i'm a
shipbuilder i can't build a ship to sink
my hands couldn't do it
and the the hound says um
well then perhaps you have to go and
work for
gaelic a finder can always
find
work
and so if you're not serviceable here's
the the key idea if you're not actually
usable by somebody else
then you're not just to be thrown aside
you're to be destroyed because you're a
possible
threat
now later on after
otter escapes from gaelic from the
mercury mine
and
leaves with anea
he goes to her village
there he encounters the women of the
hand ania is a
you know magic user herself who had
great talent and helped him to overcome
gaelic and her family
welcomes him in
medra stays with with them
for a while and they tell him something
it's time we talked a bit to you mead
says there's people all over these parts
and maybe beyond who think as you said
that nobody can be wise alone so these
people try to hold on to each other and
that's why we're called the hand or the
women of the hand though we're not women
only but it serves to call ourselves
women for the great folk don't look for
women to work together or to have
thoughts about such things as rule or
misrule or any power so calling
themselves the hand provides them some
concealment precisely because the
powerful think that women can't do
anything and then they bring out
something up they say there's an island
where the rule of justice
is kept as it was under the kings
morid's isle they call it but it's not
the the endland of the
the king
of the kings nor aya it's south not
north of havnor they say there they say
the women of the hand have kept the old
arts and they teach them not keeping
them secret each to themselves as the
wizards do
and so
this is what um
otter goes in search of
and we find that perhaps
it could be pandor
pandor before the dragons destroyed it
there's a really great description maybe
it was to escape this hunt that medra
came to pandor a long way west of the
inmosi or maybe some rumor among the
women of the hand on hosk sent him there
pandora was a rich island then before
the dragon evolved to spoiled it
wherever medra had gone until then he'd
found the lands like hovner or worse
sunken warfare raids and piracy the
fields full of weeds the towns full of
thieves
maybe he thought at first that on
pandora he'd found moritz aisle for the
city was beautiful and peaceful and the
people prosperous
he met there a mage an old man called
heydrich whose true name has been lost
when heydrake heard the tale of morid's
isle he smiled and looked sad and shook
his head not here
not this
the lords of pandora are good men they
remember the kings they don't seek war
or plunder
but
they have a flaw right
they send their sons west dragon hunting
in sport as if the dragons of the west
reach were ducks or geese for the
killing no good will come of that and
medra will stay there and study with
high drake for a while before he goes on
and finds where the actual island is
that he's been seeking
rogue
not the rock of the wizard of earthsea
with its long established school of
magic but rogue
where the women of the hand mainly women
although there are some men on the
island have gathered together
to keep themselves safe part of the vast
network they've reigned themselves into
rock and there they are recovering from
a terrible
raid that had taken place
when many of the men and indeed many of
the the adult women as well were killed
and so this is the backdrop this is the
story realm
of this particular
story the finder that begins tales from
earthsea
you